i Doan office 2007 or earlier when there
was gridlock in the marketplace I
remember there was an early intervention
by the European Central Bank putting
liquidity into the market it was massive
and the Fed followed and put in less
liquidity and I said to myself gosh look
at those guys in Frankfurt you know
they're trying to look like heroes
taking this major action and the Fed was
just following to show that that they
were there and I looked back at that one
and said to myself I was absolutely
wrong in terms of my judgment about it
that the ECB had it right and more
liquidity should have been provided to
the market earlier on again not a
cure-all but perhaps could have tempered
the impact on the market someone
you know I think that the question I
guess for the counterparties at AIG and
this is a major issue and not just swaps
but in the wholesale market and that is
to what extent do participants in their
market know the current financial
position of their counterparties and I
think the answer is people don't ask
they just deal with each other and this
has been a question for 20 years why
should i do the trade with you what's
your financial condition today and then
one answer as well if it's an
institution that trades a lot it can be
completely different tomorrow in terms
of the financial condition the credit
default swap as an instrument has been
unfairly attacked now i have my
prejudice i was on the board of is de
the swaps trade association for a number
of years but i think the product worked
well it continues to be a product that
gives us price on on securities and it's
a good indication of price on securities
outside of AIG it's worked well in
lehman there used to be issues on
documentation and I credit Tim Geithner
in terms of puffing up as should have
been done long ago on the need for for
firms to tighten up and get their
litigation that they'll the
documentation complete and someone was
telling me of the number of trades that
Lehman has a huge number of trades only
one resulted in litigation regarding the
validity of the trade because of
documentation so I think the swap worked
well that's not to say that there's not
a need for standard I swaps to be deal
help dealt with on on trading platforms
and settlement mechanisms for regulators
you know for example the basil basil to
perhaps in dealing with the trading book
as opposed to the credit book perhaps
didn't have a high enough capital charge
it's not to say everything was perfect
but I think the credit default swap was
deemed to be the evil instrument because
of AIG at AIG it was an issue of risk
management
and I put these two and say the two key
words for the next several years in
terms of Banking Supervision quality of
risk management and quality of liquidity
management
I don't know that's I read the papers
and say yes Goldman Sachs was a major
counterparty and there were many stories
in the market about debates between
Goldman Sachs and AIG on valuations and
things like that that were a bit strange
so when when someone writes the book
maybe they'll be able to give us more
insight as to really what was going on
there
well I mean if they were getting
collateral from AIG and it was good
quality collateral you know this you
know what were they doing with it
they're probably pledging it hopefully
they were repledge it with collateral
and receiving back something that was
liquid so that they would have the
opportunity if they needed to pay it
back as rates change market rates change
so to me we're talking about collateral
it it it is an issue of where is my
collateral with a counterparty that will
be focused on by examiner's the the
raynham charged on my swap will depend
in part if I have to put up collateral
whether I let my counter potty Rhea
propagate the collateral to another
party will people become nervous i had
Winston swear there was a client who was
posting collateral with the bank and the
central bank of that country guaranteed
all deposits so the client said to the
to the counterparty branch of a foreign
bank here in New York I want to place
that collateral with the bank in the
foreign country where it's a hundred
percent guaranteed so in a nervous world
will see things like things like that
happen